desde su creación en 2011 el monumento a
los atentados del 11-s ha visto todo
tipo de flores sobre sus casi 3.000
nombres de fallecidos sólo que las de
hoy junto a banderas estadounidenses
tienen el simbolismo de 20 años de duelo
y una larga guerra externa la ocasión
para unos de finalmente llegar a esta
zona huérfana
sheffield perdí a alguien que conocía de
norte smithfield era azafata del vuelo
175 milla red en su momento tuvo un
memorial en mi ciudad natal del blu-ray
land pero nunca llegué a venir aquí es
el 20 aniversario creo que es importante
más allá en apnea porque nunca había
venido no lograba venir era demasiado
triste hoy hemos dado el paso para ver
el monumento
tras la pérdida la tristeza un
sentimiento de superación cubre nueva
york' no obstante la ciudad no olvida
las autoridades han calificado este
aniversario de vulnerable advirtiendo
que si bien no hay amenazas habrá gran
presencia policial y militar con perros
detectores de bombas se verán presencia
en toda la ciudad no valoramos la 'zona
cero' como único objetivo potencial
mañana protegeremos toda la ciudad de
nuevo no hay una amenaza específica o
creíble se desplegarán los máximos
recursos para proteger a los
neoyorquinos y sus visitantes
a falta de horas para honrar a las
víctimas los primeros homenajes
políticos tuvieron lugar en washington y
virginia mientras que el secretario de
estado estadounidense aludió al cambio
en seguridad vivido en el país
observando el actual departamento de
estado podemos ver como estos atentados
nos han cambiado y han cambiado nuestra
diplomacia
sao sus move miles de diplomáticos han
servido en afganistán en irak y otras
partes en cargos que antes de los
atentados no existían todos los
servicios del departamento se han
movilizado de una forma u otra para
evitar un nuevo 11 de septiembre en zinc
un 11 de septiembre que aún vive ya que
entre otras cosas más del 40 por ciento
de los cuerpos no han sido identificados
formalmente